guys the day's finally come here it is
go to www.dopeasusual.store
and we have the sketchy tee with the
black and white we also have the
pullover sweater
we have shorts and beanies the link will
be in the description of this video or
go to www dot dope as usual dot store
[Music]
what's up everybody i am thomas
dobasiola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to another episode of the
dope as usual podcast
we're here to talk oh no no intro right
now sorry
hold on we got a chest we're testing the
water we're testing the waters
we're testing the waters right now thank
you for watching the dope as usual
podcast
back again our very first guest we ever
had you guys have asked repeatedly for
joshua to come back thank you so much
for hanging out with us how you doing
buddy man
you i'm doing well thank you for having
me you know you and i have been talking
about doing this
since we did it that first time well
that was one of my favorite
chill hangs that one the one you did
over at my house for my podcast
when you ushered me through a night of
mushrooms yes
let me tell you i was telling beth
because i went back
and she was asking me about my
highlights lives my guests and my
favorite guests
and i was like without a doubt thomas
because i went back i don't ever
watch the old ones but i was like i was
so [ __ ] up that night
i had to go watch and see what happened
again and i was like this dude
he was my shaman he he he eased me
through the journey
he never like you know like um when you
don't want to give someone the answers
but you just beat around the bushes i
don't want to tell you the formula
for immortality yeah you were kind of
helping me
like i would i would kind of start
saying something you'd kind of guide me
like that's not where you want to go
let's push you over this way
but you were the there's a camera that's
the first time i ever met joe
you know what he's on a lot of mushrooms
let's let's guide him the right way so
we can get through this here's the other
thing i knew
that was the first time we met five ten
minutes before that and i was [ __ ] up
he ate a cup of mushroom and the way and
i knew i was like this dude this is my
guy because this is the first time
he didn't even you didn't even blink the
only thing you said you were like you're
not going to swallow those with water
this dude's [ __ ] up this one was
downstairs i set up the camera
i'm like alright i'm up here by myself
all right this guy's cool his house is
tall
it's a vertical living too many steps in
that
four-story house and all these stairs
like 3 000 stairs up to heaven that
night let me tell you something
there were some nights when i got high
downstairs in the basement and beth
would text me you're coming up and i'll
be like no
i don't think i want to make that
[Laughter]
i'm not walking through the clouds
tonight there's no [ __ ] way let me
ask you
when you were moving in and you saw that
did you pre-plan like
what's gonna be bad oh yeah oh you did
yeah yeah it still went
well take it well here's what i did i
put a refrigerator downstairs
oh you already knew it and then i put a
refrigerator on the top there's like a
whole suite down there yeah dude it was
like
it was right when and when jacob was
like i need to come move back i'm like
fine we got it set up downstairs as an
apartment and he was like why is all
this stuff down here i was like
i don't want to walk up 50 [ __ ]
stairs every time i need a water
you know i'm staying down first thing i
thought like
wait you got to train your big ass dog
to just have to like hop on him or
something
oh never ending story style i wish i had
a flying dog
so i know that was so off topic okay but
but all right so
if flying dog like if you could have one
pet that was a little juji
you gonna fly a dog if i could have one
and
that that had a little extra so flying
dog talking cat
whatever you wanted to get a dog like
i actually i disagree i i wouldn't want
a talking dog you know the one thing i
like the most about my dog
he's [ __ ] quiet do you know what i
mean he doesn't say anything i wish more
of the people i loved were like that do
you know what i mean
like what i love about my dog is he
shuts the [ __ ] up that's right
what happens one night you're tripping
balls on too many mushrooms and your dog
hey don't worry fella i'm right here
oh my god this sounds like sam elliott
my dog would stand by
me i would like my dog to sound like
hank hills from [ __ ] king of the hill
i was just thinking about that before
you got here like you know hey
i need to start watching king of the
hill again king of the hills it was ten
minutes before you got here great
hold on 10 minutes before josh scared
the [ __ ] out of me
i have a gate a chain a lock and he just
opened the door
yeah i didn't close the door none of
them were working apparently yeah i
walked in and you were like how'd you
get in here i'm like well that's called
the door
i walked past the 30 camera
[Laughter]
oh that [ __ ] i just forgot to close the
door
so if the police came they were like
well maybe they got murdered because
their cameras weren't working nope he
walked right up he actually knocked and
it
opened yeah
she's usually like live streaming oh
[ __ ] yeah rosie's usually on the cameras
but i was waiting for rosie maybe that's
why i left the door open
what would you think about me lighting
this up i say light it up what time are
we at
are you okay yeah we tried to go ten
minutes without uh
smoking on the show oh did i [ __ ] that
up nope okay you're perfect timing
actually this is
and who just out of curiosity whose
handiwork is this oh rolling it yeah
oh that would be me that's really wrong
that would be me it looks like a cone
doesn't it
do you know who is a fantastic joint
roller my son
yes that dude can roll a [ __ ]
joint man i thought he was going to be
with you honestly he's working on a
netflix show oh
nice man you know i'm going to tell you
something
and you've met my son he's cool he he's
a good dude
and i've i've have three kids and you've
only met one of them but
you know what's cool man is that as a
parent
you never so jacob still lives here and
he works around people that i know
and as a parent what you never get to
see is how your
kids interact in the world do you know
what i mean
like there's a huge part of it you just
never get you just hear what they tell
you
but because i know so many people that
he's working with because he's working
on
uh tv shows and [ __ ] i get updates and
it's
so cool to hear like i'll get a check in
and just be like hey just you know your
son is a [ __ ] really solid guy
and i'm like that [ __ ] feels great
sick
it feels so [ __ ] good because i'm
like all right well that that one all
right
yeah we did that all right predictions
were correct yeah
because you never know we talked about
this in the last podcast
uh i had told a story about this guy
that picked on some
special needs girl he's trying to punk
her right so
marty said do we just take him out in
the field and just shoot him like what
do you do with that
if your kid is bullying mentally
challenged girls in school
shoot them and start like you said shoot
him and start over i said do you take
him out to the desert and then i just
trailed off so
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you the honest
truth you ready unless that kid is
incredibly troubled right and
and the parents already know he's just a
[ __ ] you know there's some people that
are just
the reason that that kid picks on
mentally challenged girls
is because of the parents so they know
do you know what i mean
most kids are born good people
and it's what happens at your house it's
what you see it's what your parents are
[ __ ] doing that [ __ ] you
up you know what i mean yeah so like i
would say
that parent might be like good for him i
taught him to make fun of those [ __ ]
kids you know what i mean that
that kind of [ __ ] well that wasn't the
case the kids died
[Laughter]
that's what i would do man yeah that's
what i would do like you got no
there's no way you can be picking first
of all
you shouldn't be in there picking on
people anyways but but
my like when i grew up man you made fun
of the people you
liked you didn't actually pick on people
if i
[ __ ] if i was [ __ ] around with you if
i played a practical joke on you that's
because i
like you i know you can handle it right
do you know what i mean
and so we weren't picking on people that
we didn't know
or that couldn't handle it because it
was too much what's better than pulling
a prank on your
friend it's so good because you know
them and you get to remind them about it
every time you see it
like you remember when you stuck that
hot dog in your ass and yeah
that wasn't it but that's not by the way
that's not so much that's not so much a
prank as it is a felon i think i think
you're not suppose
this is hey by the way uh weapons holy
[ __ ]
weapons they're awesome aren't they
dude this place looks great thank you i
know it's
dude it's been almost six months it's
crazy it went by
as fast as that we were talking about
that in the right end what have you
because we did the first one where do
you
feel like you've gotten better
at this and and i'm
more so curious about like what's the
surprise
present like what have you gotten out of
this that you didn't know you were gonna
get
and not just money but like personally
what is it you've gotten out of this
i'm super stoked every week to do this
that is huge that's huge yeah like it's
not like oh
it's more of like [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah dude that's funny one time all
right cool all right let's get ready uh
i'll get ready get up knowing how much
the fans are looking forward to it
that's why it's like
yeah people are higher the videos and
it's just
a little community i've seen the same
batch of people in the same
inside the comments the first the first
people like this is why i like you so
much man because
one you're in it to do things that you
love
and that you like and that make you
happy and
the reason your product is so good is
because you genuinely
are enjoying what you're doing so that's
fun
to listen to it's fun to watch people
who are not only good at what they do
but
[ __ ] love it do you know what i'm
saying of course
so that is super dope and you and i have
talked about this before too man when
you and i have the same ideas about
fans and interacting with fans and
giving back and being present
but i love that [ __ ] too man oh yeah i
know you do yeah sure
you actually give a [ __ ] i do that's all
that's all that matters like
do you care yeah if there's no camera
around do you give a [ __ ]
then you're winning man that's so the
camera around it
it's so true because if somebody like
i can tell there are people that i've
come and seen and hung out with here
right
and um when the first thing they want to
do
is hey let's film something i'm like
yeah but we're just having lunch
do you know what i mean that can't just
be lost yeah let's just have lunch
yeah it has to still be able to be a
thing yeah lunch still has to or just
hanging has to be something that we can
still do
yes and not have to like you all let's
do
thomas and josh hang out at his house
[Music]
[Laughter]
i uh i don't judge people on it because
some people were just
you know excited yeah i was thinking
about that last night some people just
on saturday we watched the ufc like we
just
oh yeah we didn't film anything we just
came over [ __ ] watched ufc got they
smoked so many bowls back to back it was
kind of ridiculous
but you guys were just buddies hanging
out yeah that's [ __ ] great though do
something crazy
by the way man watching that dude's leg
break
that's not my jam what happened what's
the first thing i said marty
after mcgregor's leg broke
ready yeah are you ready i hope you i
hope it's what you
don't remember by the way the build-up
was amazing because he walked back
behind the mic
yeah a damn thing and he he
the way you walked over with purpose
made me think this dude's got an answer
he's about to [ __ ] kill him yeah but
nothing i bet it was a good one-lighter
one
i don't want a [ __ ] butcher i'm
taking that skateboard vlog the
[ __ ] off yeah that is right he's like he
was about to go skateboarding the next
day
and he's like um
in the water he'd be like [ __ ]
[ __ ] break your leg like that water
i'm gonna break my [ __ ] leg when i
saw him break his leg by stepping that
was it
no that made me want to dude i like
weird [ __ ] right i i thoroughly enjoy
where's it
i don't like things like that i don't
want to see legs break or
i don't arms or blood i don't know do
you remember when people were watching
uh
in like the early 2000s beheadings and
crazy [ __ ] yeah what was it what was the
the site uh was it rotten.com that used
to show that [ __ ]
oh my god the first time i ever saw
somebody start to get their
like neck cut i just i still remember it
yeah i can't i can't watch stuff like
that now
listen it hurts me it's so bad
the only thing i'll bump up against with
that is like
you know every now and then someone will
pop a zit and like a maggot will come
out
and i'm like yeah that's weird i'll take
a look at that you know what it is
that's the weirdest nasties totally
nasty but my question is why do you have
a maggot in your forehead
like actual magic you know people like
to have like a wound and they pop it and
like a magnet
okay thank you very much yeah yeah dude
appreciate this yeah
yeah and i like what weird [ __ ] like
like like people send me weird videos
dude like somebody sent me this is a
text i got from a buddy
buddy of mine and he said have you ever
seen a video
of a dude in a in an in the ocean
in south america getting blown by a fish
and i was like what and he goes is that
a no have you not seen that i go no neo
do you wanna i'm like
yeah send that over so like those are
the type of
dude those are the type of videos like
zits maggots bestiality
don't be showing me no leg breaking nah
man i'm out on leg breaking
but the here's the craziest thing about
that fish video
the dude let's go the fish and the fish
[ __ ] swims right back up to his dick
dude let's go with the fish stop
fish swims back to the deck yo youtube
you could just
just limit the [ __ ] out of these uh ads
right
now demonetization
sorry you should probably cut that now
leave it [ __ ] that
believe that leave that [ __ ] what i'm
just letting you guys know now i
understand why
yeah but sometimes you do
you know the fish is like just dick you
swam off came straight back can't get
it wasn't it wasn't bad if you wanted to
come back yo
thank you for that no it's by the way
it's bad all the way around but what i'm
saying is
people send me weird things all the time
so what i'm saying is
other people send me stuff oh no dude i
love it
i'm not i've never say no i'm on
some weird list for sure like i get sent
weird weird things but but weird like
gross like that but also weird things
like somebody sent me um
an article that there was a small
business advertising
what they do is they take teeth out of
dead people and they make jewelry out of
it
stop it it's actually on my facebook
page stop it yeah how do they get the
teeth for dead people
they get consent from the dead peoples
and so there's like a there's like a
tooth ring
but it's one on every knuckle you just
posted this i just saw this on twitter
it was not mine it was either twitter or
facebook one of the other either you or
somebody else
is this weird ass [ __ ] yeah sorry it's a
bunch of jewelry your teeth
yeah it looked nasty but but but that
kind of weird stuff i like that i like
weird news stories
you know like there was one there was
had one headline man found naked
man found naked with hot
grease and pan and erection in the rain
where do you find these articles people
send them to me but also i
look for them where do you live for do
you just google
the weirdest [ __ ] yes i think yes
i google show me no josh
[Laughter]
hi yeah dude that's actually what you i
weird [ __ ]
that people wouldn't think to post yes
weird [ __ ] that nobody else wants to see
that's my wheelhouse man i love it now i
don't like gross
i don't want your leg break i don't want
to see your head explode i don't want to
see anyone die
no i want it to me
okay to me the people in the video
most of the time can't be have to at
least be having a little bit of
fun you know i mean it can't be a
suffering video yes i'm not
in for this so that you know you know we
didn't know that fish would like to suck
dick at first
yeah we found out after right oh the
video's okay yeah yeah
at first you were like what's happening
right now and then
uh by the way he had a friend filming it
that's a good friend right there who do
you ask
himself that's the i'm like that's the
craziest part
who do you ask do you know anybody that
well
to to to broach that subject hey man
hold on hold on i'm sorry did he call it
fish latio
yeah yeah did he really i know he didn't
because that's [ __ ] funny yeah
did you just make that up yeah okay rap
and ass marty over here making a [ __ ]
word i love it i call it fish lacio
buffalo here we go
thank you i don't know how to rap here
we go
[Applause]
[Music]
you [ __ ]
was the best thing we ever did yeah i
thought it was at the jersey shore when
you hit me with that right there
we got a couple tricks up our sleeves we
got the fan going you don't know we have
a new fan
we have updates we have a fan we have a
different table two ashtrays this time
yo i'm high yeah me too sorry guys i ate
some edibles right before we started and
they're
actually stronger than i thought they'd
be yeah
all right marty you guys it's medicated
um take home cookie dough
it's so good by the way i'm eating some
right now it's like
it's vegan and it has my [ __ ]
name on it and it's in the stores it's
from cosmic
times dopaziola i'mma tell you something
right now dopisto
it it is delicious
that's a marshmallow because i told you
they go we have all these things we can
put and go can we do it all
yeah yeah we can yeah [ __ ] yeah then
dude
it is like so if you like the way cookie
dough tastes
you're gonna like this and if you don't
like the way cookie dough tastes
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you how have
you lived your life
how do you not like the taste of cookie
dough get your [ __ ] together
even when i found out don't eat it wrong
you get sick i'm like oh i've already
ate a whole
yeah do you mean if i eat the whole
batch i'll get sick
or just just a little bit oh yeah nobody
i look man this is i could
when this was in front of me as a kid i
couldn't that's the one thing i could
never
smash the whole thing if my mom left the
kitchen i'd be like
how many cookies did you think you were
gonna make
30 yeah because drop that even though
hot out the oven is like it it's like
two different
foods to me it's not health is amazing
to me i still take this
really over cookies over hot even over
hot officials so
high as [ __ ] talking about cookie
preferences [ __ ] this is relevant that
[ __ ] is delicious yeah yeah yeah
did a whole video on it it was in a
whole video i was eating hello cookie
dough and then i was like you know what
hey
maybe i should slow down a little bit
you've got the podcast and i ate the
cookies after
and um they're definitely rolling up
you're like popping them in like
looking meat i was rolling
they're delicious as [ __ ] they're really
good man they're really good yeah you
did a great job
now do you when you make something like
that do you taste test it as it goes do
they send samples and
everything before we make sure every
single thing
we like is on point first and so was
there anything that was in there that
you were like man
maybe you know we shouldn't put the
whoppings in there huh
no revisions no revisions
thank you and i texted the guy
immediately kevin shout out to kevin
from cosmic
yeah we uh made it it's called the
dopest dough it's got marshmallows
chocolate chips and sprinkles
he's like we do one we can do this this
two different like just throw it all
into one
and one container it's so [ __ ]
because they sell cookies in a tube
i was like what about just somebody
could take it home and do what they want
with it
or never make it back to the house i'm
[ __ ] hot
yeah well for half an hour almost now
i'm just saying the first 10 minutes we
technically weren't recording
oh that's right we're just talking about
that's hold on your wife that's what it
was
your wife oh that's right yeah you were
asking me does my wife smoke weed
she does not the last time she smoked
and i actually think it was an
i think it was an edible but she's
definitely not smoking the last edible
she took
she threw up and she thought she threw
up her teeth
and that's where we left off well she
was like are those my teeth
and you know i'm a comic so i was like
yeah i'm making jewelry out of my head
yeah
i'm making a knuckle sandwich right now
yeah exactly
right and i go yeah and she was like is
that my teeth i'm like no it's not your
teeth why would you throw up your teeth
and she said i this is i threw up my
teeth i think she said something like
because she thought that she thought
that weed was like
like making her am i a bad person i'm
like no is that why i threw up my teeth
because i'm a bad person i'm like oh she
was just lost
she just she was good and so bad
yeah and so she was like i'm never doing
that again and i was like yeah that's a
great idea how long ago was this
gotta be seven years oh that's a long
time ago yeah yeah it got to be seven
years but
but still when she's like maybe i should
i'm like nah
let me tell you something when she has a
something that's 10 grams of cbd and 1
gram of thc
she's high as [ __ ] really hits you that
bad
yeah she's high as well that's cool i
guess [ __ ]
your weed lasts [ __ ] eighth last a
year yeah
dude yeah no she um that is not her
thing and but
luckily she likes me i think she likes
me better when i'm high
why well to be honest you tell me
because you i feel like you're
almost always high she likes me better
when i'm high
because when i'm not high like sometimes
i'm like almost i'm
knocking behind for like a week or two
and she'll be like all right
and then at the end of two weeks she was
like are you gonna start smoking again
soon i'm like why she goes
cause you never shut the [ __ ] up when
you don't smoke weed you just talk
all the time and i'm like yeah you're
right i should probably
she's like josh is like one of those
dogs that yeah
i'm just jumping over her back the whole
time what are we doing where are we
going what are you doing what's your
name how you doing what's going on
that's awesome dude she's trying not
smoking the golden stage
oh yeah don't know during those two
weeks
but all i want to do is get on stage and
she's tired she's like man you try like
97 jokes on me a day when you don't
smoke weed what about this one she's
like shut
shut up but just for god's sakes but by
the way i'm glad she tells me
yeah because i like smoking weed every
day
you know what do you she's like a good
shower she like watches over you takes
care of you and [ __ ]
she's great she yelled down when you're
tripping too hard
you all right
yes nice to meet you yeah yeah yeah
that was that yeah she really you know
the best part about her
is that she really lets me maybe me
and how long you guys been together
we've been together since 2001.
but she she
look man you know i'm not a conventional
guy
i'm just and i and i like things that
are a little weird and
um i'm very malleable i like to kind of
go with the flow sometimes
and she just lets me
do that with no ques she never questions
me
and it's it's it's amazing
because i don't know what i i'm just
kind of a like a loosey-goosey free
person that doesn't mean i'm not [ __ ]
around
that's not what i'm talking about but
you know i'm just like to
you know sometimes i just get up and go
and do [ __ ] and she just lets me
be that person it's super dope have you
been in relationships where it wasn't
like that
yeah but yes i also
wasn't in those relationships as sure as
about who i am you know what i mean
yeah so she's really as i've evolved
into
kind of how i do who how i am right now
she's let all that happen it's been
super cool man
like that that's when you know that that
person's in it with you
yeah because you're out there you're
like a self-made channel like
your goal is like seven days a week
you're putting out shows it takes a
supportive person to be like
do your do your own thing build up your
own business don't be
putting all your time and going out and
trying to build up stuff for other
people basically
yeah and she by the way i mean
she is selling tv shows she just shot a
music video
she was bossing her own what does she do
yeah she's a writer director
and so like she that is that i'm
assuming that's how you met
when you set up yo we met we we had the
same manager
and if i'm being honest the first
night look man at the time i was single
i was raising three kids
by yourself by myself and i
had built myself up to like a seven out
of ten happy
right which felt so much better from
where i
came like right after the breakup and
all that figuring out how the [ __ ] i was
gonna raise three kids all that [ __ ]
right
and i had hit a seven out of ten and i
had really made a mental note that you
know what
i can't sink back down i'm raising these
kids right now
i'm happy i'm i'm not gonna be in a
relationship
until they're way older like and so i
was
summarily dismissing people and how old
were you when this happened
it was like 1998
so 20 whatever with three kids by
yourself
in hollywood we lived in one little room
i mean i made like 1100
a month what the [ __ ] were you doing for
a job
oh dude well i had to get creative
i had to get creative is the best way of
you know i [ __ ] did whatever i had to
do to get
money well that's what you do man and so
i had to get crazy
uh like when the summer came around
i couldn't really work because i had
three kids and
that daycare is more expensive so
stressful you're not from here so you
don't have your parents here
and family so my i lived with my brother
but he worked do you remain my brothers
worked
so when i needed to work they were
working
and so
i it was hard for me to know when i
could work too
and so i comic no no just to make money
in general yeah and so like i i you know
catering was a good one because i could
kind of book advance and all that stuff
oh [ __ ] this is on our list down there
um yeah i was gonna say throw something
out there can you tell me something
about this
what's pb j's oh and that was during
this time
boom i was just doing his research that
was there that was during this time did
you know that
no oh okay i just saw something i didn't
read anything i'm like
i'm gonna
so when i was telling you that you you
do what you have to do
to make money so
long hair josh oh yeah long hair josh oh
maybe not my three kids
maybe not too long by yourself yeah
okay so i i started this peanut butter
and jelly delivery service
just peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
well so
it was not code for drugs no drugs no
kiss none of the kids
so so for two weeks we walked up and
down
this was a while ago man so i knew i had
to deliver food with three kids
it's not like there was a bunch of
people answering phones it was me
and i had a and i had a pager we didn't
we didn't have cell phones so
i we the first for two weeks we walked
up and down
sunset boulevard and hollywood boulevard
near where i lived
and into the office buildings and
just handed out menus peanut butter and
jelly menus
and so on the menu was like peanut
butter jelly peanut butter fluff peanut
butter and honey peanut butter banana
sick
right [ __ ] love those yeah and a in
triple decker
and then on the you could order like a
yoo-hoo with it
you could you could order um
some otis spunk meyer cookies cause
there was a woman in my acting class who
is the otis spunkmeyer
rep and so she had a ton of samples and
she knew what i was trying to do so she
just gave me
she used to give me all of her samples
did you bring the kids with you
everywhere you went
okay so we and then we and then we
and then i would write this how i
practice jokes
is every lunch came with a note from
your mom
and so you could order your note mild
regular
spicy are you talking about so i would
write a note for the pbj's i would put
it in your brown paper bag lunch
that's how you sold the these right so
they so you'd get a sandwich a yoo-hoo
a bag of chips cookies whatever extras
you wanted to buy right
and um and then a note from your mom
that i would write
and so if it was you wanted it to be you
know
plain it would just be like good luck in
your math test honey
your dad and i really believe in you
love mom
and i would put it now a medium one
would be like um
okay uh um
like uh hey i'll see you when you get
back from the gym
honey uh i can tell you've been doing
your squats
something like that love mom love mom
and a spicy one would be like you know
your dad and i broke up it's over
between he and i
i think you're really cute or whatever
you know what i mean it's just dark
company right that's how you ordered
your note that's how i
i practiced joe it's funny did you think
about
your you're going around with children
selling sandwiches
with no no i don't know you knew what
you were ordering
and the kids couldn't read
[Music]
no but that didn't bother me little or
were they yeah
probably six
or maybe seven seven five were they
working for you or were you dragging
them along okay so this is what we would
do
i would i would dress them up so they
didn't look
super clean you know i mean and they
would they would bring their brown paper
bag
lunches in on a red wheel barrel barrel
you know
and um barrel is that what i'm talking
about cart uh
let's just say it's like a wagon a wagon
wagon right they would bring it in under
the wagon
and um and their lunches would be in the
back
stacked up in their brown paper bags the
kids would bring them in
and the older kids would you know they'd
know about the money because i had it
written down
and they would get the money and the
reason we sent them in is
better tips they're cute they're cute
man they're getting real tips
yeah they kept all the [ __ ] change
when i went in it was like hey
what i'm like got it send the kids back
i'm the one that runs the notes though
yeah yeah
but yeah so what we call the pb js i
have a menu
frame at the last menu i have it framed
it's up on my house
in my office yeah um but we did that
because
i just couldn't figure out how to make
money
while they struggle everything yeah so i
had to make money with them
so get creative you really did get
creative and it wasn't just
i love that i had to do anything i could
no my going up in the buildings like
that yeah
yes it was not what i thought but
i brought them with me so the they they
were like oh this is the
this is the menu with the little kids
yeah and basically here's what i thought
it would be
once a month nobody's gonna order peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches
more than once a month but once not for
an office but once a month they'd be
like hey let's
order from those kids and then you just
had to get to enough
offices yeah that's all it was you just
had to get to enough officers just look
like the best dad ever like i'm teaching
my kids some
goddamn discipline well i was using them
for tips let's be honest
all right [ __ ] okay we got busted
so there was a got busted dude
we thought this was all friendly and you
were doing good what are you saying
no no so we're making sandwiches
lunchtime the lunch rush is happening
and there's a [ __ ] knock on the door
and uh i'm in the kitchen making
sandwiches and i hear dad
kitchen assuming your house uh my
apartment okay and dad
and i'm like yeah and he's my older son
and goes it's for you
and i turn it's this guy in a suit
clipboard
and i have no shirt on i'm making peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches my hair is
all
[ __ ] crazy i got peanut butter in my
chest and whatever you know
and i'm like yeah can i help you and
he's like
yeah is this pb j's i go yeah but we
don't do dine in man we only do dine out
i go out we can deliver it to you but we
don't nobody eats in here
and he goes i'm from the health board
and i was like no
i go what he goes is this
where i've been eating he goes is this
is this
where you make your sandwiches and my
kids
wear a little conveyor belt on the they
would make
sandwiches they would just put like the
my daughter would put the sandwiches
together and hand it to my son
and my son would wrap it right and that
way i could just
do put a bunch of peanut butter peanut
butter peanut butter jelly you know and
do all that other stuff right
and i would put it down for them well
what i didn't know was happening at the
end of the line
is that you know my son had like peanut
butter or jelly on his hands and he
would just reach back and let my saint
bernard lick it off his
finger and he was closing it
[Laughter]
did people people were getting hair in
their there maybe
but we had repeat customers i mean
people liked that that dog hair
apparently but
saint bernie said oh yeah i forgot the
saint bernard lived with us too dude
and so the guy goes hey guys this this
is not okay
and i go which part he goes all of it
all of it's not okay
he goes these are your workers i go well
i mean they're not really my workers
i go they're my kids and he goes yeah
that's that's not better
you know that's not yeah
he was like you can't do this he was
like i'm shut we're shutting you down
you're making sandwiches on the [ __ ]
floor well technically
i would he we had a big blanket down and
it was like
we had a blanket yeah i had a blanket
then it was all very sad
it's a very picnic setting yeah it was
exactly what it was because like
when i did it on the table for whatever
reason
they fought with each other but if i put
them in front of the tv they would just
mindlessly put them together nice
yeah i love it i love the 90s this is
fine
no that's what happens yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's amazing yeah yeah yeah no it's
they
yeah yeah so you gotta shut down we got
shut down we gotta shut the [ __ ] down
there yeah we gotta shut down then they
started selling drugs out of that
apartment
yeah they really no oh but the apartment
next to us were these
lesbians who did a lot of heroin
and they also sold omaha steaks what the
[ __ ]
yeah and so one they had a real long
heroin binge and you could they were
just
basically all the steaks just went bad
in their apartment they never put them
away
and they were just in there just
thinking that was that was a bad couple
of days
we had a guy dude we had a guy holy [ __ ]
we had a guy
okay you ready for this we had a [ __ ]
guy what was the battlestar galactica so
he was
a klingon and he had told us always
wanted to play
klingon and a movie and he was one of
the people like an extra or something
but he got to wear the makeup
and he would come home with it huh
because he was because
it was his dream you just walk around
like that yeah
in the [ __ ] apartment complex he'd
come back and he'd be like okay
i guess this is what we're doing you
know what i mean okay
looking good was it cool
okay let me finish my story oh sorry so
this so and he would always the only
time i really saw him is he would just
be in his robe
no shirt just underwear
and throw his trash down the trash chute
and one you know every now and then i'd
see him with the klingon
mask doing it or or he had a samurai
sword
that he would walk down the hall with so
this dude got arrested because you know
poinsettia parked either one of you no
point
this dude got arrested because i think
it was poinsettia park i might be
getting messed up
he killed a
prostitute with his samurai sword
no at the park and he
and he got arrested in his klingon
makeup
what a badass that's a sad story but
yeah what a [ __ ] sick ass way to end
up
in jail were you in here what the [ __ ]
on your feet what are you in here for
i just stabbed somebody with that right
yo he's definitely getting like getting
left alone first night in jail
you know this crazy [ __ ] coming
in below klingon [ __ ] dude
but but what an amazing story i'm so
happy i'm not happy that it happened
i know what you mean i'm so happy that
was your neighbor so we got that because
that's amazing that building had
just during that time was just a story
after
craziness all around i cannot believe
that you raised three kids by yourself
well i mean
luckily i met beth and so how long were
you
single dad in it where was this thing
come
at it's a struggle it's literally just a
guy who [ __ ] you was brett
you dude [ __ ] dude okay so guys
stressing out in the apartment
it's like some pursuit of happiness [ __ ]
but way more way way mixed with
shameless
dudes you know and i'm sure have you not
i mean i've told this story but like we
didn't have money right
so and i had a saturn that didn't have
any air conditioning because i bought it
in
seattle and so it
why does that matter if it's in seattle
you didn't need ac
because it's cold up there it just never
got until like this year
it never got hot hot so you could always
just roll down your windows and be fine
gotcha and you people they did sell it
but you know that was an option to not
have ac
yeah i i'm not sure they're gonna sell
it up there without it but
you could definitely and one of the
problems with the heatwave up there this
summer is that a lot of the houses
didn't have ac
because they just didn't need it i
yeah i yeah it's been a long time a long
time since i've lived up there
so wait uh how long were you
single dead oh like
three and a half years damn that wasn't
long enough for a sitcom
a movie yeah multiple seasons
holy [ __ ] what else did you do to get
money what are the
did you have to take a bunch of odd jobs
i'm assuming this is this is the [ __ ]
i've never heard
or catering helped catering helped a lot
uh and i yeah it's just a lot of
like every now and then like there was
this kid this guy
matt oh i can't remember his name
but he was just a dude who always looked
out for me and he would be like hey i
got a gig that pays five thousand
dollars
and to me at the time five thousand
dollars was like
i could probably live for
three months and with three kids i mean
because i knew like i wouldn't want to
but like i could make
that work i could make that work and um
so i was like [ __ ] but when things like
that would come up
and my brother would be like yeah man
absolutely
when is that yeah we'll make we'll make
this work you know and
so i got i would always kind of get
lucky that way so i didn't have to do
too many of the
pb j i did a lot of catering i would
start my own like comedy rooms i think
we were the first
i i don't want to speak out a term we
were one of the
early shows at the melrose improv
that i think we did one of the first new
faces
shows down there and one of the first
people that they let book their own show
like the clubs let people book
you know the rooms now sometimes or yeah
and i don't know that they were doing it
a lot
back then i could be super high and not
remembering but i
don't think so but so we did a lot of
that you know i was
good buddies with joe diaz and he was
always good for a dog
i got a gate that pays 200 but you got
to be able to get out of that at night
and that's why babysitting uncle joey is
what you're talking about
yeah because joey diaz babies have my
kids yeah so you can go do these things
right go do stuff yeah yeah yeah go do
stuff
it was he was yo man
he really saved me
for a while just because he was just the
guy that i could be like can you watch
the kids for an hour
and he was always like yeah i got it you
gonna make me a turkey burger that was
always the deal you're making turkey
burgers i'd be like yeah i'll make a
turkey burger yeah i'll come over and
watch those [ __ ] kids
that's a whole nother series that's the
whole [ __ ] story in itself
when the [ __ ] did this start dude buddy
here's what's crazy and i've said this a
million times
he okay joe diaz i consider him to be a
moral criminal so if you leave twenty
dollars on the table
and it's your twenty dollars he might
take it
but then he would take you out to lunch
with the twenty dollars
and then he'd tell you hey you get the
next one
you know what i mean oh my gosh
no he's not that way anymore but like
that he was that so
but i'll tell you something he he
oh no but he the reason he for me
for me like none of that mattered
because i also knew
that he would take a bullet for my kids
i i knew he was jumping in front of the
bus
so all that other stuff to me
whatever the eight dollar an hour
babysitter would i'm they're not
jumping in front of the bus joey's
jumping in front of the bus so
everything else to me was real secondary
sure he didn't wear underwear a lot
you know what i mean so maybe his ass
crack was out more than it should have
been
sure but builds character
yeah man especially when you're high
level but like
but but but i for me the important thing
was like i always
felt safe leaving him
with him that and that was that was the
biggest one yeah that's the most
important thing holy [ __ ]
marty's had a few babysitter experiences
that maybe you want to enlighten us with
i'm talking about your drug addicted
babysitter that you had no idea was a
meth head how do you not know somebody's
immersed
i was telling thomas we didn't really
have enough in buffalo all right
first thing i asked like how the [ __ ]
dude i didn't know somebody that was on
meth
let me ask you a question they didn't
have math in buffalo but do they have
unhealthy looking people
do they have people with open sores on
their faces
zombies like me right now at this time
she was pretty in this world yeah yeah
it was
she was the before pictures though
really
yeah but then yeah later on it became
apparent how long did you
she was only she only baby she was our
daughter's first babysitter and she was
probably with us she probably babysitted
for like two months she was my wife's
like
best friend two months yeah wait and it
was
best friend i did not know this part of
the story
yeah i just realized babysitter that was
crystal man it was her best friend
yeah you guys didn't know she was doing
drugs yeah not
not meth in particular that came out
later because her life spiraled out of
control afterwards
oh [ __ ] we need to combine your story in
that story
you know the math is it
it's a parrot yeah it wasn't a parent
i did set up this little makeshift nanny
cam though that was literally just a
little point
just to make sure i mean we didn't have
any way i just was my first dog
like you know what this spot in the
hallway is a good way place to roast
[Music]
i had to point at the tv you know just
in case
just in case you changed it with our
hands
[Laughter]
we had another babysitter off of
care.com coming to our house
just like the nicest 23 year old girl
came in
had we looked at her resume oh this is
great but the picture we like ended up
emailing one of the references and the
person that wrote his back like when she
had signed up for this fake email
account
she had entered her actual name at some
point so it was like the username but
then we saw the real name was the girl's
name
and then i googled search the profile
picture it was some politician
so we write this girl back like who are
you giving us phony references you can't
even sat in our house like
yes his doubt fire went out of your way
to give us a phony reference
it was like that type of scenario so it
was extra creepy and then we just never
heard from her
yeah because you kind of figure
if you're doing kid stuff
you're gonna check the reference yeah uh
you would think so
a hundred percent of the time that [ __ ]
leads into
lifetime movies yeah that's what if you
do not check that's what i felt like
yeah
because she's like oh i'm on vacations
you saw marty [ __ ] working out
smoking a joint
in the in the garage like you know i
need to overtake that family
i would be a babysitter did you did you
watch that
series what was it called dirty john
deere
oh it's like three different times yeah
i watched one episode while i was
editing rosie's watching i went
it's just kind of hard to follow and i
just kept editing and suddenly
yo that first season i didn't watch any
of the other ones that first season
is it cool it's so good is it really
it's so good i only watched parts of it
when i was editing
that's all i've seen no no that first
season is legitimately good i
i don't know about the i i never i'm not
a good season two guy man
i got it's gonna come real quick after i
feel you me and marty the only thing
i've i've been watching where i'm like
every week waiting for it to come out
like like an [ __ ] what you want
it was we were watching handmaid's tale
because that shit's watching the whole
time
damn near i'm gonna say your if it's
your opinion
it went up against breaking bad in my
mind and it won whoa
i was real disappointed at that third
season but it kind of came back in the
fourth and um
okay so i'm gonna on that
i want to watch that show because i kept
thinking that it's
not for me it's out there is it
and it's eerie yeah i wanted to explain
it to you it happened before
it was made before the pandemic but the
whole storyline is like oh god this is
eerie all right okay
yeah fan uh dude see we were talking
about this earlier like saying because
it's on hulu people might not know that
what the [ __ ] it is but it's one of the
best shows ever and why
is that but i mean chet i'm curious let
us know if you watch this show yeah it's
just wild as hell
you should watch that i've been watching
dave dave's really funny
yeah it's like herb enthusiasmish is it
funny
the first two episodes i went oh this
shit's not funny and then episode three
i'm gonna go okay here we go
and i've been watching every episode i'm
waiting for it to come out is that the
little dicky one
yes i'm just sitting here waiting like
hurry up [ __ ] i have to wait
every week like a normal person
oh i don't like it it drops once once a
week yeah it's like a normal show using
that binge watch [ __ ]
yeah i feel like uh no you know what
that's going to take us off into a crazy
other rant
that show is wild have you seen why
women kill or snapped
all right rosie watches all these death
murder shows unsolved mysteries
i've refused to watch unsolved mysteries
me and her made a deal
we will never watch it cause there's no
ending that's true
yeah yeah yeah i'm with you i'm waiting
yeah you ever seen that sport called
thai
no exactly yeah boring is [ __ ]
terrible yeah yeah
every time there's no satisfaction
nothing it's just
by the way if you can help us out here's
our number
all right unsolved mysteries hey
[ __ ]
help yourself that's not my job thank
you yo
every time like by the way we don't know
anything
if you can help us get a story too part
two episode that would be sick call this
number no credit
this is here's i hadn't thought about
that that's you know what's you know to
me
you know what's more [ __ ] than that
the self-checkout at the grocery store
why you like it listen man i love it
then give me a discount for doing the
job
do i get a discount oh oh you're doing
you're making this easier for me
is that right it's not easier it's not
easier it's not easier and
it's easier for you because you don't
have to hire as many actual
people for sure but you're still
charging me the same amount of money
of course okay so the only reason i use
it
oh no line yeah it's because it sucks
exactly all right yeah i'm going to use
this
i'm just to me that is like listen
and like the [ __ ] beep put it in the
it's in the bagging area yeah
put it in the bag no wait it has to
weigh it so you have to stack [ __ ]
out yo i feel you 100 that's funny you
said but why
why this is all i'm saying that's the
biggest one the biggest one is like um
it's like those restaurants where people
like
yeah you want to go to that place you
know that place where you cook your they
bring the food around you cook it i'm
like you mean my house [ __ ]
i don't want to go somewhere else and do
that do i have to wash the dishes there
too
i'm out on going somewhere else to cook
the food
i'm tipping you are you out of your tree
that's a great i agree
i know i agree you know what i'm saying
though
set it up and go yo no the stoves put
them out by the seat yeah
no no tables just put a little bar right
around this hot ass plate
they'll cook it no they'll clean it yeah
we'll pick it all up
[Laughter]
we'll throw we'll throw egg and butter
at them make jokes
and they'll be like oh yeah and oil in
the fire
but it's so funny yeah don't watch these
fools do this [ __ ] [ __ ] with the
fire
i get stuck i'm just i'm just i'm just
saying yeah
there's some fun parts to it and wait
i'm
the place where you cook them it's a
korean bbq yeah i don't eat that [ __ ]
stinks yo i can cook my own terrible
food at my house yeah it's not fun
nah like yo you put it on the hot plate
that's why i that's why i got dressed
i put pants on i got in my car
and to drive somewhere else to have
someone else do it
do you know what i'm saying like yes do
you ever have the awkward stare of
or who's going to be the first guy to
offer to do this yeah
i don't want to do it maybe he'll pick
up who's the grill guy
yeah who's the guy that's going nobody
i've been in that situation well i don't
i didn't come here
to do all the work i hate that [ __ ] yeah
it's not fun
yeah i mean [ __ ] i don't even think i've
ever been to one of those it's not fun
you're not really for vegetarians yeah
no it's not that's why i haven't been in
so long yeah but the times i did go
yeah it's hot i like the ones where they
shoot the [ __ ] sake and they throw
the
that's the benihana stuff yeah yeah yeah
that's fun what you talking about is not
fun yeah
at all i do like the bunny honey guys
those are fun they're having a good time
really really bad one you ever have a
guy that has no skills but he's just
like
i lined up my resume well just chill you
ever have those guys
are super over enthusiastic they were
cowboy hats and they go
they [ __ ] shoot it at everybody
they're throwing [ __ ] out what are you
talking about buffalo against wild
all i hear is just like we're 50 cents
walking through and get rich don't try
and
[ __ ] yeah listen i'm talking about
[ __ ]
it's not called benihana it's some
off-brand [ __ ] but they
put some enthusiasm into it right
enthusiasm yeah yeah i'll hear too the
one mercedes is the one i'm talking
about the guy was not
good and it was is it funny you kind of
want to like how about like give me some
examples of how that
is so you try to do the egg roll thing
and then crack it
and he kept hitting it and it kept
sliding away
and like yo bro just crack the [ __ ]
egg yeah like what are you doing you're
looking
like a like an idiot right then he kept
trying to do the pepper in the fire
and he just like it got to the point
where he was trying to do these things
it was like a bad american idol audition
you know you're like oh i feel
bad because you seem nice but you're
also trash
terrible and you also you you just stop
thank you yeah yeah exactly oh you
forgot to put that uh
just oh yeah i ordered hey here's what i
need you to do with this man here's what
i need
i need you to look at all of our faces
read the room [ __ ] yeah dude
none of us are enjoying ourselves clean
up if you enjoyed my service you can
leave me tips
you just want to look away it's like
when you see like some drunk ass fool at
the intersection asking for money go
he stares at you for 30 seconds i hate
that [ __ ]
yeah they're still there ellie's the
worst for that we're just talking about
it when he lives there's no bums
this is socal i mean orange county area
it's
clean i'm staying i'm staying in
hollywood
because good so i'm staying this is it's
like bizarro world for me
i'm staying at jacob's apartment and
driving his car oh
sick season four of arrested development
it's just a role
you should leave a [ __ ] mess in his
car have you
no i'm going to tell you it's not it's i
mean look
it's not as it's it could have been
way dirtier it was it was fine i was
like
you should do things that he used to do
in your house
and just do it to his car like oh no by
the way i smoked all the weed that was
in the compartments
you know it's crazy [ __ ] i texted him i
go hey where's your weight he goes no i
took it all
i go what are you guys yeah i took it
all
are you weedless right now uh i have
weed if you want to leave
i mean i haven't i have that joint that
i have oh no how long are you here for
it ellie
i leave friday oh i have a bag of wheat
for you then
oh okay thank you yeah smokey you can
smoke it by the time you leave
yep marty whenever you can can you get a
bag of weed from that box
thank you i have a bad week for you
yo so like i said earlier yeah i ate
some edibles
and i completely feel them and i'm
trying to wake up because i feel like
i'm high
[ __ ] we're just i mean exactly what
conversation i haven't looked back at my
notes really at all
to start con we've just been talking
about this random thing which is great
and then i went oh yeah [ __ ] i wrote
[ __ ] down let's see what you get
hit me hit me did you see the article
about
uh we might be confederately legal i did
not
take it away what did you say
federal legal federally legal weed
yeah [ __ ] i mean in my uh [ __ ] news
reportings i
read that they're about to [ __ ] make
federally legal
passing bills doing whatever the [ __ ]
they do i don't know where did you read
that
multiple places on instagram oh on
instagram i'm getting my marty's second
my marty i'm getting my info on the
second hand
shots of websites are you wait did you
little things
are you saying multiple sources on
instagram yeah at least two
to three i independently googled this
earlier and i don't
listen i don't know [ __ ] about
government or how they do things or pass
bills
me neither google it yeah
oh yeah by the way here it is here's
some weed this is my friend cannabis
brothers
how awesome smoking look at the picture
on the back it's them in the 90s look
how awesome that picture is
come on man isn't that sick yeah
it's a half zip so you can smoke that by
the time you leave yeah
yeah i'm excited thank you so much for
that no problem
what is it this is the new york times
schumer proposes federal
decriminalization
that's not federal legalization
listen ooh a new party listen
because there's that's two different
things what decriminalizing
and legalizing oh it's just three
criminalizing well the first thing said
decriminalizing but then the second one
said legalizing
all i'm looking for is youtube to stop
getting butthurt over this [ __ ] whatever
needs to happen for that to happen with
these laws
federal legalization bill doesn't mean
legalization bill there it is oh no i
just skimmed through
this is big senator bookers and i are
releasing our draft legislation and the
federal prohibition of cannabis
yeah the wordage that i read was like to
right the wrongs of the war on drugs
type of [ __ ] like letting people out of
prison for
non-violent uh weed crimes [ __ ] like
that
i mean that would be an epic day
for humanity that would be huge
because new york's league or
recreational or medical
um i it's recreational i
think but i don't think the stores are
open yet they don't have dispensaries
yet but they won't
like allegedly rip you out of your car
and search your car um
all that type of [ __ ] that so i was just
in albany
and that's why i was like where can we
smoke and they're like they're not gonna
say anything to you outside
and i was like well outside the mall
they're not gonna say anything
and they're like step away from the mall
i'm like okay
can i smoke right outside the [ __ ]
front door you mean right here
right now walmart greeters smoking a
joint [ __ ]
just a little further dude like outside
the hotel
but yeah that's huge yeah that's amazing
that's super dope i honestly
i i honestly didn't think
it would get proposed i thought it would
eventually
in my lifetime obviously but i didn't
think it would be this quick
i think in the next two years
i mean 2023 at the latest people must be
seeing
states must be seeing how much money
it's bringing
that's all it is they're trying to
figure how can we tax the [ __ ]
that's it like yeah do it hurry up look
you do it already with cigarettes
you tax booze let's make money too
figure it the [ __ ] out
figure it out it shouldn't be so hard
you don't but not do you think 21 21 or
18 for legal age
18. but then
like when people will say but alcohol is
21. why should we yeah but
i could still like yeah and i got to
make everything 21 if it's a dollar
let's walk a straight line you can go to
the army at 18 so
yeah for real i can't smoke weed but i
can go shoot people well listen dude
you're not i'm just playing devil's
heavy yeah yeah
i would say that i mean if you're 18
you're gonna you're gonna [ __ ] get
wheat if you want to i mean
that that is true like i don't think
legal
look legal weed some people might
try it obviously there are more people
trying it now and but trying it
and using it for like useful reasons
right i
just know a lot of people like oh they
take a gummy if they can't sleep and
[ __ ] like that right
because it's better than ambien and all
that other [ __ ]
so like there's some more people who are
doing that
who are new to weed but that's not like
they're [ __ ]
a zillion zombies walking do you know
what i mean no
just right now just two right now yeah
just me and you
but you know this is a reason for
zombies
we're gonna watch this tape back and
we're just gonna be uh
we just feel right now that it's okay
wait are we not talking oh [ __ ] none of
the cameras are on are we not talking
you guys are just telepathically
understanding each other
i'm kidding um i do have something we're
an hour in
i didn't know you had a show mm-hmm you
have a show tonight where
it's a laugh factory factory where which
one
hollywood is this your first set in l.a
i did one last night at the comedies oh
did you yeah there you go
it was a ton of fun man it was a it was
so i hadn't been on stage there since
february 2020 probably
and so it took me you're in like what
yeah like 14 15
15 months it took me yeah it took me
like a couple seconds to relax
it was just you know exciting but i love
that feeling but
but it took me a couple seconds does it
feel did it feel different at the comedy
store
yes being different yeah yeah
different energy how could it not yeah
not better or worse
just this different but i i don't know
if that's
due to the comedians i think it's just
due to people
being out of the house and
you know the mood you went into
this quarantine with was most people
were in an angry mood
right and then we get angrier and
angrier and angrier because you're just
inside the house yelling at strangers
right because they must be the problem
and then when people finally get out of
the house they're so happy
so i think a lot of it there's good
energy at
a lot of places right now because people
are just [ __ ]
this is so you know no matter what you
think and what i think
we're just both happy that we can be out
of the [ __ ] house do you know what
i'm saying like
for sure so like this is this is good so
i think that
what i mean the energy i think it's
mostly that
for sure because this time last year i
was walking to the elevator ah get away
from me
yeah hey i gotta spray down everything
get up get away from me yeah
yeah it was like horrible last year was
like a [ __ ] movie
last year was like they were gonna open
truman
i love you just in the sky like by the
way guys
we've been [ __ ] with you that's how i
felt last year was
i moved two days before quarantine
started
you did yeah i moved to burbank two days
before quarantine started
and i looked out the window like three
days in and there was a ghost town
it was the scariest [ __ ] feeling ever
seeing nobody no cars no nothing yeah
dude in a new place i didn't know the
way out so i didn't [ __ ] find all the
stairways like
oh man this is [ __ ] something on the
top floor [ __ ]
oh dude oh my god bro this is zombie
land out here
and did you did would you did you get
out of the house for food what'd you do
oh yeah i went out got a bunch of [ __ ]
came so like it
three days in the corn four days into
quarantine someone's trying to
not kick my door in but there was just a
huge pounding on my [ __ ] door
like trying to get in my key and i ran
over there and
whenever i guess the person heard me
stop and they like walk ran off
yeah but when i opened the door and look
he goes i'm so sorry i'm so sorry he's
like i thought it was my apartment i was
trying to get in
my key didn't work i'm like all right
yeah
yeah yeah all right man and he walked
off
so from that day before we had the
warehouse all the push trees gear all
the clothes
was in my apartment so i only had my
room and everything else was clothes and
racks and
just yeah i remember stuff yeah oh yeah
yeah i remember
yeah yeah so all that used to be stacked
in front of the door
every time i left every time i went to
take a trash out every time anything
i stacked all of it in front of the door
because that [ __ ] guy like yo he's
trying to come back in here
it just started quarantine maybe he's
trying to see who's living in here which
apartments are empty like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
so i started getting all paranoid and
then i stacked it
so through the first three months i'm
just thinking oh no
right and then about
five weeks after that guy did that i'm
all high let's get off the elevator
walk i'm opening the storm like why is
my [ __ ] door opening
and i'm looking and i'm on the wrong
floor but my apartment
and they opened the door and it was that
guy no i'm so sorry
why
[Music]
but that makes sense i'm so sorry and it
makes perfect sense
yeah because i get it now yeah i was
over here like every night was that
noise
yeah oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] you heard me like
no i gotta get oh [ __ ]
how people are going crazy just doing
drugs and [ __ ] how long after
the first accidental walk-in did you go
to the dude's door
how long ago yes so you had you were
paranoid for
weeks no i was paranoid i just stopped
putting stuff from my door like
once a couple months ago what will you
put in front of your door
anything anything that i can hear in the
middle of the night so i can go
you're going to get shot
just letting you know tell me give give
me an example of what you got tell me
what you what do you get
it used to be the racks and then it
turned into two hampers and then it
turned
a chair with something on it so i can
hear it fall in the night
now did you ever walk into the other
room and
call out like knock it over let me see
if i can hear it
yeah yeah yeah rosie goes over there
be quiet hold your breath yeah all right
for sure we can go
sleep now i'm not kidding at all yeah no
i'm with you what was the
loudest thing you had up the rack of
clothes yeah that's probably then i put
the rack of clothes
all the canned food every single thing i
had yeah it took like 10 minutes to get
out of my house
my paranoid ass that was it yo uh what
happened
we just started talking about my entire
setup my house so what time do you go to
the room little do we know
josh right now now you can break into
his house right now
i heard where he keeps all the sweet at
and his mushrooms
the little bit of mushrooms i have a
little bit we talked about it last time
i don't have a lot of mushrooms don't be
thinking
let me tell you something right now over
mushrooms are the best in tennessee too
um
they're not quite the same no
no no not the same as california
[Music]
so uh you have a show
yeah so i didn't know that that's how we
got to this topic
i may or may not have a business
proposal in this envelope
and or psychedelic substances in this
bag
youtube it's just what
we give up all right bro just wait for
anything white flag
[Laughter]
we're not showing mushrooms but there
may or may not be
mushrooms in here yeah that's hilarious
the lifeline
i didn't think about it till right now i
mean that is great
um do you want to take some
also you have a show this is the only
time
that i'm like hey we don't have to do
drugs yeah but we also don't have to do
drugs
you see what i'm saying yeah you know
look i can i can get by high
i wouldn't take the mushrooms i don't
know i can't
here's why all right give you these okay
you ready my friends yeah you can't show
it my friend started this company look
oh right that has all the information
where they're grown
all this stuff it's all branded all the
[ __ ] it's vacuum sealed and everything
in a little container i love so cool i
can't we can't show this
and this is my friend's company there
are a bunch of uh jail capsules they
have thc and 100 milligrams of
psilocybin
per capsule so tscn like the silica and
psilocybin
capsules golden teachers
uh per oh 100 milligrams of cbd the
other ones of the thc 100 milligrams of
psilocybin 100 milligrams cbd
per capsule so
take these take these oh i haven't got
those yeah
with that sounds just read it it's very
cool
like i wonder what that you know what
thank thank god for your show
because right now if i wanted to eat
some mushrooms i'm already like this off
these edibles
dude i gotta tell you i here take this
for the
hotel uh yeah
i um thank you so much for this by the
way
this is very kind and normally you know
me
and that's why i want like when you go i
gotta show tonight
yeah you know me i'll eat whatever the
[ __ ]
that's actually tattooed right here
that's how he used to pick up the ladies
whatever
they have like inspirational quotes and
[ __ ]
that's a little
i got it as a [ __ ] [ __ ] stamp that'd
be so tight it can't rain all the time
across his back um
we're just talking about the crow i mean
about sting did you just remember sting
the wrestler
yeah he still wrestles how's that
possible
he's still buff what he's like look it's
70 years old
where is he wrestling it said awc
what is that i think that's a movie
theater look at him
he's still [ __ ] bugged oh look at
this dude
what's going on how is he still above uh
i pretty much said a different person
just keeps getting passed down with the
makeup
i mean that'd be kind of tight they
never said anything that would be the
way that would be the way to go this
dude's like 32 here
that's a young picture of his ass i saw
the old picture of it he
he looks older hey google old stink
google old st is that him
look at him you know you know with that
picture with him in the glasses
he looks like nicholas cage nicholas
cage is standing
yeah yeah yo what happened i was gonna
say the wrestler
the wrestler from our last episode
reached the dude that
oh yes
marty brought up a clip last week yeah
and it's a guy fighting a guy in the
street
and he ends up you know the guy bent
over he has his head between his knees
and he picks him up in the street
drops him on his head like sits down
pile driver yeah wow in the street and
walks away
leave her alone the dude was chasing the
dude the dude like caught up to him
on the concrete about the topic we were
talking about wait wait wait wait wait
wait
they were fighting just bam between his
legs pile drivers him probably
then we get a dm and some it says caught
me in 4k
and it's the guy that piled driving him
dm does because he watches the show and
he goes yo that's me
that is so dope and then you look and he
doesn't mean he's a musician and he what
is it
he's a wrestler i love this guy yo he
uses his skills in real life he did what
he was supposed to do
whoa could you imagine you're just
[ __ ] with some dude on the street but
he's a
actual wrestler he's a wwe style guy
how cool is that i gotta tell you
something listen man for real for real
like
and i was joking around about it earlier
but
that's what you're supposed to do it was
awesome
that's what you're supposed to do if
you're that guy i expect you to play oh
i've gotten a fight with
x-pock and he [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out
of me and suplexed me
by the way dude you know what like i was
thinking the other day
you know about i was writing a bit about
just things you did as kids and but you
don't do as adults
and one of the things that i was like
you know one of those things you don't
do
you don't you don't you don't give piggy
backs anymore
because now you can feel another dude's
digging your back
that's i don't that's it like i think
that's
that's the only actually the only reason
why it stops
like hey yeah as soon as it wasn't fun
no more like you know
yeah you can't do chicken fights yeah no
and the one on the sh let me get a
drowning let me get on your shoulders
no no no you dick on my neck i don't
wanna
how are we gonna chill yeah you're gonna
keep hanging out and then we're just
gonna go watch a game i don't think so
dude
like uh i mean if you're into that
that's cool let me know
but but as of now i'm like oh it's [ __ ]
it's so there is it's just one year it's
okay
in the [ __ ] next summer you're in the
pool and you're like not okay anymore
did you ever have that moment where you
were coming of age and you realized oh
everyone else is going through the same
exact [ __ ] thing i
am did you ever have that moment like a
specific moment you can remember
right now no i can tell you actually
quite the opposite
it wasn't until i was older that i
realized
when i was talking to my kids and i was
like about everybody oh [ __ ] everybody
goes right i'm like
everybody that's right that's right oh
that's not what i meant
because oh he goes through tough times
like a coming of age like uh
what i'm talking about is i went to a
pool party i was like oh my god i got my
first like five zits all and they all
came in the night before
like yo i'm like this is what i have to
do everyone's gonna make fun of me [ __ ]
i get there
every single like wonder years and then
i realized that everyone
had sits all over their [ __ ] face and
then that girl started her first period
while we're having the pool party yeah
and went whoa that really took the
tension off of everybody
his [ __ ] acne right now super safe
but
it just happened it was a wonder years
moment that's what i meant dude
like growing up [ __ ] yeah that's i
remember that
yeah like when you realized that like yo
i i love i was so happy that i wasn't
the only kid
who wouldn't take his shirt off to go in
the pool like there was a couple of the
kids at the pool and i was like all
right
oh we had like five thousand i was like
yeah i [ __ ] see you we were all like
essays i studied rock shirts and [ __ ]
my stone clothes shirts getting faded
from this chlorine but yeah
my brother told me when i was younger he
told me i had
meaty nipples and i was like i'm wearing
shirts
[Laughter]
i just wore shirts he was like
he was like man you got meeting nipples
and i was like get the [ __ ]
what [ __ ] but i
i put a shirt on immediately yeah i was
like with that well that worked whatever
you meant to happen
did congratulations dude i used to have
long ass hair i used to have long hair
and you know what i mean
and i thought it was awesome i have a
picture i posted one time i was like all
along
and then one time this guy at football
practice looked at me and says
hey man you look just like rosie
o'donnell oh no
i come out here that day i was so
[ __ ] like
yo you're so right and i [ __ ] despise
you
too now
she wasn't good at the talk show but jay
leno was good at the talk show
so she was like the lady that wasn't as
you know what i mean
remember her talk show yeah why did she
ever stop but it was so popular i heard
ricky lane control
ricky lake was the [ __ ] but her and
ellen were hella big i
i remember rosie o'donnell i think she
just
didn't she get into tv like doing tv
shows and movies or was that pre-sh
i don't know i just remember her the
flintstones yeah and uh a league of
their own look at their own though she
said a lot of stuff too that's all i
remember
but let me ask you something how long
did you have the long hair for two years
and nobody told you no i didn't think i
looked like rosie o'donnell
until he said well [ __ ] you like rosie
o'donnell
oh no no you piece of [ __ ] yeah
do you couldn't have told me this two
years ago no i loved it i would have
kept it if you never said [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying rosie o'donnell
made me think [ __ ] i
do look just like rosie o'donnell
[ __ ] you i'm out and i cut my [ __ ] all
the way off
buzzed buzzed my hair but anyway that's
my coming of story
coming give a story um that was it
i don't know why we brought that up i am
oh yeah no mushrooms here
and the train's actually rolling in to
let us know that uh
we're gonna be okay to keep on trucking
and to keep on rolling
this part of the podcast brought to you
by amtrak
thank you oh marty that's actually josh
you're already here
you know this train interferes or
actually this train's part of the
podcast
it's part we know it's it's called a
care package i mean
so you know what time it comes by every
night no sometimes
it just shows up sometimes it wasn't
come all day i'll be here packing orders
for [ __ ] eight hours
yeah and then we started filming it
comes four times that's
she said yeah well hey
yeah yeah that's that's definitely some
long hair thomas would have said for
sure
i was busy doing mushrooms and i didn't
do my homework
yeah by the way that's a great excuse
yeah
i wish we talked about i really wish i
would have tried better in school
i was a 4.0 student and i started doing
drugs and went you know what
i don't care yeah but okay because why
not because why you stopping i stopped
uh putting all my f
i used to be like obsessed with how can
i get a straight 4.0 and be like
no but why why are you bummed that you
stopped
trying sorry um because
you know what i'm not bummed because
everything worked out exactly yeah right
i'm just when i if i could think about
what's one thing you would have done
better like tried in school
i would actually gave a [ __ ] i probably
would have done really good
that's it yeah but like that's awesome i
mean it's cool to want to be
better but it wouldn't have made me
better right yeah
and you're just thinking about high
school yeah that's the only thing i
really [ __ ] up on
is not doing it you know what i wish
high school had ended sooner
i just been like for me oh i hate it
yeah school is the worst
for for me like i even look back at high
school
and i'm like what what are they teaching
in there
what what did i learn exactly why did i
like although my high school you did
have to take like a shop class
or a woodworking club yeah or something
like that right
and so i always i was like that's cool
and i'm not saying you shouldn't be
teaching like history in
english and all that [ __ ] but also like
they should have some
for high school kids especially just
some real beginning ideas of what how
they should handle their money
we [ __ ] about this all the time we said
we want to bring a financial advisor on
the show
let's just have them explain money to us
yeah if i'm 18 tell me if i'm 25. you're
trying to buy a house at 30 something if
i'm trying to do this
how much did you go to college i saw a
lot of comments about that last episode
i got a lot of names like this youtuber
does a great this right
look [ __ ] you if you if i'm sure there
are people that could tell you
or if you're a 25 year old person this
is how much you need to put away every
week
to have this when you're 40. so just
remember that
if you in 20 years if you want this
that's the sacrifice you get
like somebody who could break it down
just
like that you know what i need someone
that can talk that i can talk to and go
yeah if this is too hard this is what he
said tell me again
yeah this is what he's saying right here
yeah that's how we need it we needed to
break it down what if i'm
telling you like i'm 10 years old yeah
10 years old 10 years old
i've watched the show how much i did you
know i was telling this stuff forget who
i was telling this to
today but we used to you know when i was
poor
when we we used to put ious and
jacob's piggy bank you know and i forgot
about him
and so when when we
how old is he well when we broke over
the piggy bank
he probably was probably i forgot all he
was teenager and i heard him go
well we just kept putting him in and you
know we just can't put money in there
like it was like one of those giant
whatevers
and he would take his money out of there
right it was so bananas
so he was probably he says bananas
like how to steal it from my kids the
stealing
stealing stopped when he was a lot
younger you know we had grown away from
you to justify taking money from your
kids though you're like i'm like you
live in my house [ __ ] you
i'm like you don't need this why do you
need this 20 bill we have to eat like
that was it was during that time when i
was like
that's just [ __ ] hilarious oh dude
and the iou's at the bottom
i heard him go what is this i was like
what
was he talking about and he's like how
many years did he have it
he was like do you owe me like 400
dollars i'm like what
he's like you owe me like four dollars
there's like
a bunch of ious here did you take my
money i'm like
oh yeah years ago yeah i sacrificed
everything for you
i was like yeah i did take your money
but i think this is the statue of
limitations is up on that how long do
you have that piggy bank for
he probably broke it up when he was
probably 13.
i mean how long did he have it for it to
build up that long
he's probably so excited he probably had
it for seven years oh my god
could you imagine the [ __ ] anger
like dumb and dumber yeah oh gonna want
to hang on to that one
yeah listen we and there would be times
using the briefcase this was this was
the bet when we got a little older and
we still didn't have money there were
times where i'd go into the room and i'd
go up
amen and go yeah i go hey i got a
hundred
i just got to break it and he'd be like
okay
and uh i mean i had a 20. i took 100.
i was like thanks dude he was like no
problem and then
how the [ __ ] was he making so much money
my brother would dump money
in his like my brother had cash on him
and he would always dump money in there
and i would see him dump money and be
like
got it oh no groceries
coming this week
yeah here on the dope junior podcast
we're here to talk about life
stealing from your kids drugs
pb js oh man you know what dude
i i love that you did all of these
things
because you had to well i mean
yeah it was every it was all hands on
dag
that's it you know what i mean she had
three kids by yourself that's insane
just for a little
circle back for [ __ ] three hours ago
but just for a little bit and then beth
hopped on
when beth hopped on board it was just
like so much easier when you have help
not just help like she was she and yeah
somebody just who's all in yeah she was
all in
and so that made it so much easier but
there were times
like i let my i let the kids dress
themselves because i was like that just
is one of these things i can't worry
about
some big daddy type [ __ ] frankenstein
yeah but now
now i felt really bad for my daughter
because i was the only one around to do
her hair
and so her like oh my god
my dad yeah he's the funny one her
ponytails
you had cool hair though you couldn't do
ponytails
no your hair was tight yeah but i
couldn't do both you had a picture last
time you heard that picture was
hilarious yeah no i couldn't i can't do
photos
i i can't no it's hard enough just to
brush their hair they're screaming you
can barely get that's right you have
dodgers
got rubber bands going and [ __ ] but she
yeah my daughter but she had
yeah she was the best super cute let
them dress themselves
but yeah man and then beth hopped on
board dude i can tell you when
beth met me i didn't smoke
at all not unlick really
he and beca you know whatever has
why yeah
because god forbid
something happens and in the [ __ ]
news article
weed or whatever be where it was like
god forbid something happened and i was
high it would just be
i would never it would be just
impossible for me to even come to grips
with
so did you like weed before oh yeah
oh so you stopped when you became a dad
that's all when i became a single dad
oh see that's just super responsible
that's all that is you're very
responsible but that's what i mean when
so when i met her
i didn't i didn't really i didn't not
that i didn't really i didn't smoke at
all
and then a little while then with her
she was like
do you smoke i'm like yeah now i do
tag team i'm gonna go lay down yeah i
think i'm gonna go get high yeah
[Music]
since when you get high since you moved
in yeah thank you but actually
[Laughter]
yeah real dirty like no
drugs yeah yeah she was like here's an
adult he's raising his kids and she
joined the boat and i'm like
let's get [ __ ] up yo what a flip
that she must be the [ __ ] then i'm
telling you to put up with that
i'm telling you i'm telling you what is
this this is like
you going overboard you you [ __ ]
what is that kurt russell goldie hawn
overboard overboard that's what you did
to her except
except all you did was no i'm really
like i'm a comic and i'm raising
it was the single doggy dog i think it
was the single dad thing i'm not gonna
lie to you she told me what really
hooked her
was we were talking on the phone and i
was making
turkey burgers for the kids and my
daughter
came up to me and said something and i
said what do you want on your turkey
burger baby
and she said as soon as you said that i
was in
that was it that's all and she was like
that's all i needed to hear you say to
her
she was like i'm gonna i'm gonna hang
out with this dude for a little bit see
what's up
he had a sign yeah dude oh come on
they were all so cute and jacob sealed
the deal that night
caitlyn lured her in and jacob see
we were out on the couch we were
watching saturday night live
and uh because my babysitter canceled so
she had to come over to my house
and um so we just sat at my house
and then jacob came out at about i don't
know whatever time snl is on out here
1am 11 30.
yeah and so sno also was probably around
12 12 30.
yeah 11 30. i can't remember it sounds
right either way yeah and so
so it was probably around 12 or 12 30
and you know he came up woke up in the
middle of night and he was
a four maybe a little before four
and he was start was just rubbing his
eyes like that and as soon as he came
out like that i was
i was like oh he just sealed the deal
good job buddy yo big daddy's basically
yeah yeah he just said
the big guy yeah he knows his life but
he just sealed the deal and he came over
and he had a blanket in his arms yeah
and he sealed the deal and he sat on my
lap
and he said can i have some juice daddy
and i said
yep she said [ __ ]
don't you see what i'm trying to do here
bro
yo how sick would that have been but
yeah
yeah dude it was he sealed the deal he
had a juice box
he sat in her lap for a second
and then i'm pretty sure this is the
plot to big daddy
it's pretty close you got to go back
this just actually happened all right in
my mind
from the same mom so i
met a woman she had two kids we had a
kid together
which is jacob yep and then when when we
split up i kept the three kids
bam just for a little bit and then
you know my older two kids went up and
lived with my ex for a little bit they
both came back and forth over
you know over the years and
uh and jakey just stayed down with us
and so yeah
wow yeah that's how that worked i would
say you had three kids by the time you
were 20 something damn you were
starting early yeah no man you know
i did i mean i still had jacob pretty
young
and i was a young dad i'm so glad i did
it young
because one because i didn't stress out
about
not having money do you know what i mean
like i
when i'm like i didn't grow up with a
lot of money okay
and so it felt
uh almost comfortable to be broke
do you know what i mean i i i said the
norm it's like nobody's expecting more
than this
well no what i mean is like when you
grow up if you grow up in it
until you break yourself out of it
it's it's your normal it's what your
body is comfortable in it's comfortable
in that whether whether that
environment causes you chaos or stress
your body
is comfortable in it because that's all
it's ever known do you know what i'm
saying yeah
and so like uh
[Music]
yeah that that kind of helped that kind
of happened
to me throughout that that period
because i kind of grew up with no
with no dough and so when i had no money
in that room
it was bad but i wasn't panicking
because i was comfortable in not having
money
i was like i know how to survive this
yeah i've been you know what i mean
and so we we ate weird [ __ ] dude
okay we i used to serve them black beans
tuna fish in a can with cheddar cheese
and hot sauce
that doesn't sound that bad but it is
weird
i used to serve them we would have
i want to know we had i loved um
these are probably i don't know if these
are crazy uncommon
see you've had us if you had a syrup
sandwich
you toast the bread you put maple syrup
and sugar on it yeah we would put butter
or maple syrup and paper yeah
really good but it's fun yeah we made um
rice tuna fish in a can
with sesame oil hot sauce
oh yeah and so it was all stuff it was
all stuff like that
you know but just something i could make
a giant pot out of
and we could eat because rice would go
so long
and we would just do that [ __ ] though it
was a weird time
but man
we had a [ __ ] we had a good time dude
we had a good time we did we had a good
time
it was [ __ ] fun i'm look i mean [ __ ]
i'm kind of in that probably that same
age bracket that you were in then so
it's cool to look at you now
and just having raised your kids like
what really mattered
dude what matters you you look i don't
look back and think about
anything negative from that time i think
about the
like yo we didn't have any money so
we went to the park a lot for
a long time they do you know what i mean
we were out the [ __ ] side like we we
didn't have any money so
our amusement park if they wanted to go
on a roller coaster
i used to put them in the base so i had
that saturn right
and i used to put them in the trunk in
an empty parking lot and i was not
two donuts just town to drive around and
run over
the speed bumps and [ __ ] and that was
their roller coaster that was sick i
just kind of
wriggle them around and [ __ ] like we did
dumb [ __ ] like that that's a bomb
but yeah i mean
you grew up with no money you figured
the [ __ ] out yeah you just played kick
the can
actually dude i love kick the camera so
fun yeah i have no [ __ ] idea why
when you smash the can flat and you
start kicking that [ __ ] around the
weight
and it has yeah it's just like oh do you
think you can get that past me [ __ ] you
becomes a game dude it's addicting
almost like the [ __ ]
paper football [ __ ] yeah what was
your favorite after
like school uh game that you played at
recess
where's my dad
[Laughter]
i'm kidding a few times
after school it was [ __ ] kickball
yeah
two ball wasn't [ __ ] all the other kids
that had no money too but oh
your mom works full-time too you're yeah
you know dad
i'm better than you yeah you want to see
who's the poorest
and the shittiest kickball player today
yo dude
man there was this one kid who i i was
like make sure
it was always hey jason just make sure
you tie your shoe this time
if just tie your shoe they would never
touch you it was always ball and shoe
and everyone was like [ __ ] tie your
shoe
i mean it did was i got it noise tied up
tight
[ __ ] several days
i know i know that i think back of the
anxieties were
all right first year sixth grade
now it's like first day sixth grade [ __ ]
yeah let me go in
i'm gonna tell us to eat a [ __ ] dick
i'm gonna tell this [ __ ] to [ __ ] off
like if i can go back it's it's it's
[ __ ] hilarious we're just talking
about
it we just started watching the show
about middle school kids
and it brought me back man about those
times of
wow the only pressures i had were just
oh [ __ ]
not even real pressure they're not even
no and then now that i think about how
did i
overthink things so much as a kid well
you don't know any better than that
it's unreal to think of when people were
saying don't worry
i've been through i'm [ __ ] 40 listen
to me from experience
shut the [ __ ] up what are you talking
about i don't even know your name
like oh he was completely [ __ ] right
that guy wasn't
it's crazy yeah [ __ ] your parents told
you yeah
it was right a lot of it because because
you really
no matter how many times a grown-up
tells you
i've been where you are you're like eat
my dick you have no idea
this is an old-timer you might think you
know yep
every time you might think you know but
you don't know
whatever but then when you get a little
older you're like yeah
got it guys most of the time they were
right most of the time most of the time
like you have no idea i can't re-up on
any weed right now
because i [ __ ] up and bought a bunch
of drugs this weekend and that's why i'm
like no i'm in a predicament leave me
alone
i'm only trying to figure out how to
make my money back so me and joe can
get more weed from sam i i used that was
my [ __ ] price
i wouldn't understand that i couldn't
tell her i don't know i couldn't say why
are you doing bad in school like you
have no idea
i'm trying to [ __ ] make money at
school i'm not paying attention what
this [ __ ] you're saying
i'm asleep how much
how much could you sell at school in a
day
um it depends on which kids you're
selling weed to
mm-hmm if you sound weak to kids that
sell weed too a lot like a
i don't know a couple ounces maybe at
school but
we the most we ever do is the ounce at
lunch time and one lunch recess
i mean one lunch period one over we went
over it yeah so that was the most we
ever did
but it was like a little ten sacks ten
sec twenty twenty twenty twenty so it
worked out so
during one lunch though yeah well the
first one two
we hit them all over the [ __ ] school
so we didn't have them on us
but that's friends are over here
twenties are over here it was [ __ ]
that's
crazy it was sit me and joe what was
that what was it good like what's a good
day's work
oh just selling it all so we could smoke
all the [ __ ] we made but how much
how much would that be oh i don't know
uh
we were getting taxed at like 280 an
ounce
at least and we're selling it 10 bucks a
gram essentially
no no no it was like point .8.7 was a
ten sec
so every gram was like almost 20 bucks
grand point two was 20 bucks
so i don't know we were making a couple
like at least 150 bucks
but we're smoking it all we only saw we
just smoked weed for free
and get like dominoes or some [ __ ]
you know it's all [ __ ] and i was
splitting all the profits from joe
no matter how many sacks i sold in my
humming sex he saw we split whatever we
made
that's awesome go nuts at lunch and just
zoe to everybody how old were you
15. i met this dude it was my best
friend for a long time
and uh yeah dude that was so fun
let me tell you let me tell you how
differently we grew up ready
my buddy gary miles he got in trouble
because he was selling single pieces of
bubble gum
for 25 cents each right when the pack
cost 25 cents total what grade we are
eighth that's it you got trouble for
that right he got a lot of trouble
yeah who the school yeah the school was
like man you can't sell this but this
dude was
breaking it in gary miles was my buddy
this dude
he's quadrupling his money he was making
it i think that
yeah he was making his dough for sure i
mean he was always
a smart smart businessman but that gum
racket
killing it in the 8th grade with
bubblicious if you had gum it's like
having drugs in high school
oh like yo you got drunks in high school
at a party
yeah you got a party like you got hell i
can't even surge
crazy drinks you're the [ __ ] man you
know if you had more than one type of
soda in your refrigerator
what do your parents do for a living
thank you if you had anything in your
fridge you're sick
if you if if you like if you had like
what i would consider
an exotic if you like a grape if you had
enough money
to get the all of the sodas you want and
then the grape
i'm like this dude it's got soda money
soda money yeah
you're doing okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
you got your money you got seven months
you're living checking
like soda pro you know we can go get a
shasta three liters yeah dude there's no
99 cents
zero dollar tree uh-uh [ __ ] you cans
so did the cabinet you had a [ __ ]
steady job soaring can you bought
anybody that has soda in cans and you
see them like oh your parents got jobs
oh for sure yeah
that's what i'm saying like oh my god
you have so many cans holy [ __ ] these
two liters are the
cheapest thing on the planet yeah the
dollar store you get the three liters
that cheeky punch so dude cheeky punch
like [ __ ] cocaine
or just the thing that just says cola
you're like
got it it's really good actually the
lemon lime drink
lemon lime's a little you can tell that
it's
it's not sprouting yeah no that is not a
sprite
but yeah we yeah man
but i think growing up like i think my
kids i think growing up without
is not terrible for you yeah it sucked
though
let me let me just back that up that
sounds like a the [ __ ]
not like no running water no above i'm
assuming
without like how we how i raise those
kids for a little while
because they it wasn't for their entire
childhood
do you know what i mean they have to
appreciate it wasn't
it wasn't their entire childhood it was
just a piece of it
and for that piece they realized that
like oh yeah and so i
think they all still have it sounds like
an awesome little [ __ ] chapter in
life
do you know what i mean i think yeah
this is your [ __ ] baby you know
you're
playing pb j's in hollywood with your
dad and [ __ ] like where's this movie
i'd watch it seriously i truly watch it
that's [ __ ] amazing you got the
crackheads next door with
all kinds of [ __ ] going on you got the
fda at the door we had
we had a guy next door i had a saint
bernard who was throwing rocks at my
saint bernard
and because my saint bernard was barking
at his little dog and his little dog was
barking up
my eyes saying but her name bud and so i
i hear like it sounds like something
like rain on a tin roof out on the
patio patio whatever that [ __ ]
sliver yeah and um
and my dog is like barking over the side
and i see these little pebbles coming up
i like over i go hey are you selling you
throwing rocks at my dog and he was like
he's barking at my dog
i go dogs bark at each other and he goes
i don't wanna bargain with my dog
i said well then tell your dog to stop
barking at my dog
and he was like what an unreasonable
thing to start doing so
he was like i don't think the pebbles
are gonna fix it no and
he said that he was basically he said
i'm gonna keep throwing them
unless he stops sparking my dog
i may have said something
that he took as a threat and
so i think it was probably i forget how
long
it was long enough that i had forgotten
that he
called cps on me and the report to cps
was my neighbor
allows his kids to walk on top of the
railing
of his patio and he's on the i forget i
think i was on the second or third floor
i forget
i forgot which one i was at whoa so
i got a visit from cps
peterborough jelly sandwiches on the
ground yeah this was after
they still had it in them there's still
conveyor belt peanut butter and jelly
that's big daddy what's happening out
here
i think welfare checked on you i think
this was after
you know dude and that's my own house
the welfare guy so i was still with my
ex at the time
and the welfare guy look my ex was a lot
of things
she was also a very funny person funny
funny
and um so
he's like is this a bad time i'm like no
and i forget why
we had forgotten he wasn't coming or
maybe we just didn't open the
mail which is very possible there was a
stack of mail around that time that just
never got opened
you know i have one right now yeah yeah
yeah
so he's like i go can i help you he's
like i'm child protective services i got
a call
about your kids and i was like oh
or maybe i had i think that i just
remembered i was like oh my god that's
right
i knocked on the door and my ex had been
out
i go hey you gotta come out here is that
i think i said something vague like it's
that meeting and we forgot about that
meeting
and so we're sitting at the
our dining room table at the time was a
an old barrel that somebody had chopped
and made into a table
and and so it was real tiny and all the
stools
oh just a barrel and all the stew it had
a
table top on it and all the stools were
little barrels
and they were super wobbly and they they
were small so you always kind of sat
you know like that but we found it for
free
yeah yeah yeah and so yo man we needed a
table you know
and so we took a drive we actually
[ __ ] found it
yeah we found we drove i think it was on
the streets of hollywood to tell you
what it kind of lends itself to your
serious street furniture
yeah no for real for real so i'm sorry
i'm holding this
you're good josh you gotta do we gotta
get you out of here at 10 30. what time
is it oh wait what time is it what time
is it three
oh yeah yeah you gotta leave soon at
least soon you have a set tonight
oh my god it's been two hours [ __ ] yeah
um so we
printed out something oh yeah
it's because i rant so much and i just
don't stop talking sometimes and me too
we relate that's why it's okay to hang
out and say we
that's why this works and we're like hey
oh [ __ ] two hours [ __ ]
pb j's adam seller
so we made this and we're going to give
it to somebody like
we're just going to give it to somebody
patreon raffle yeah look what marty made
rant city because i always say damn it's
rant city out here i can't be stuck i
can't stay on topic
that's awesome how cool do you that is
nba all-star quality cool right
this is all-star weekend quality and you
got the [ __ ] white pen
he knew what's up you know what's up
my uh handwriting is what i guess you
call dog [ __ ]
and so you've said one of our dimebag
patrons is gonna win this right now
we're gonna raffle it off oh that is so
dope
so how how do you do it okay so i
figured that out
mid-episode yeah we've never done this
before
so i just wanted to give somebody
something all right so let's let's do it
like this
since you're here i made a spreadsheet
with the um
with all the dimebag members on it and
then so everybody's assigned a number
and then we went to the random number
generator here in google and we're just
gonna let it do its thing
go for it okay all right so i'm gonna go
ahead and damn why are you so [ __ ]
good with this [ __ ]
shut up
number 19 number 19
who's number 19 on the thing
juan aguilar
oh [ __ ] you got me again
number 19 1 aguilar
[Music]
[ __ ] up thank you for reminding me
thanks oh my everybody's trash this pen
is amazing i'm pretty high me too josh i
told the fans you may or may not sign
that too
why am i signing it you and thomas have
a long history now of signing our uh-huh
or quark first you probably don't
remember the first time oh i remember
the artwork
i got hd pictures of it oh my god
oh no do not press down on the paint
vent
don't press down on it about that much
you know the thing about how good that
cookie dough was so i was like
i'm not gonna eat that whole thing
because i already ate a hundred
milligrams and i have to go do this set
and and it was just so good i just kept
eating it it's gone right it's gone yeah
i ate a whole [ __ ] tub earlier too
the whole thing without even no no no
moment
what's going on no hesitation this day
i'm gonna tell you this set
is gonna be i'm supposed to play guitar
in the set there's no way oh so your
live show we watched it watched it at
home watched it live
your guitar set i did not jesus christ
also don't press down on this too hard
and don't hit that joint
okay did you see what happened to me
right now unless you want that effect
holy moly oh damn that shit's hitting
hard
i put thanks for watching because i my
handwriting is bad and it's not even bad
right here
legend all right sorry
i talked
uh the whole
time
rant city baby yes
yeah you're better at this damn you got
the signature down
damn that's a [ __ ] pro little message
right there that's what you leave up out
of delhi
a deli signature oh marty what the
[ __ ] that in the middle
yeah man
you better say straight on the streets
for buffalo and it better [ __ ] have
that energy yeah
right out of the streets of
[ __ ] buffalo you better write
this for some buffalo braves energy
damn marty has the finesse too sorry for
everybody driving we're actually just
signing a poster so i know you're not
knowing what's going on signing posters
out here you have to
you have a set right now holy [ __ ] yeah
we gotta hurry
yeah i get it it said bills or die damn
bills or die
how [ __ ] your mother oh my god why are
you writing that how quickly
do you think it's real how quickly how
quickly you think i get an uber here
quick all right all right where do you
got to go
uh in hollywood yeah you gotta go to the
live factory hold on
i wouldn't close it yet do i have my car
no so we can we can take oh
we're closing up we get uber here quick
we can uber
quick all right um yeah all right let's
wrap let's wrap up then let's wrap up
you got to get out of here i didn't i
really didn't think about it i'm super
high
me too it's this yeah what's gonna
happen
during that set gonna be awesome and
then take these mushrooms let me know
how you like them yeah
by the way there's zero chance that i
am going to play guitar tonight you got
it in you
you have it in you i did not i don't
want to be responsible for people not
being able to see you play guitar
guess who's responsible for it this
[ __ ] guy
yeah ultimately i guess but i don't want
to be partly
you know i'll um don't want to promise
anything people are going to know the
dates they're like hey man you're going
to play guitar
you can't do it here's a promise i don't
think
anybody who's coming thinks i'm going to
play guitar
i just texted everybody on the list that
bought tickets and they were like yo
actually
we're really hoping josh plays guitar
tonight and i hope he has mushrooms and
i hope he eats them on stage without us
knowing
oh my god
me tell you something i was just
thinking about it i'll bring the guitar
on stage
just for effect and just see how i feel
yeah i'll bring it on stage and just be
like
yeah maybe just touch on it oh i don't
everybody goodnight
i don't have a strap i've never played
standing up in my life
i can only play sitting down it's funny
you're sitting down i think it is man
it is i think it is
also it's a little more for me
less to think about oh cause you have to
move your leg
yeah i'm just feeling a little less
awkward staying off sick and just
falling
yeah like you know sometimes when i
watch someone play guitar i'm like he's
not moving at all
but i wouldn't be either so i don't want
to be that guy
and then you see these dudes doing flips
jumping off [ __ ] amps
playing guitars and sliding damn yeah
that's why you're getting paid like that
and i'm on a stool
plucking one [ __ ] chord at a time
[Music]
but dude i've been having a great time
playing guitar
and i uh i
did so much of it over the last three or
four years i just shot a special that
was just
music wait it's not the live one
that's not a live one no i just did it
three weeks ago oh really yeah i'm i'm
off oh
first 15 minutes is probably 13 minutes
just
stand up and then i did i
so but it was a total of an hour and
thirty the rest was all music obviously
i mean you know talking while i'm up
there and and i had to get
into another song i had guests come up
did some of that on the live show the
live one i watched
yeah yeah yeah and i and and um like um
who's saying with me uh kris kirkpatrick
from nsync standing with me
and uh a woman named taylon
i also had you know an nsync member
helping me out oh
chris is a good dude man and so we
wrote a funny song and um
when i perform it i always have him come
to it with me
and so he's and he's great dude he's
really funny on stage that's awesome
so but we had he he stopped in
um there was a woman named taylor lynn
who
okay in the first so i i
sing a song it's a dumb little song
about a dude with man boobs right
and so i hire this dude to go share this
who's got
so i can't take boobs yeah but more like
meaty nipples
like me oh like maybe
maybe i was thinking meatloaf for fight
club yeah that's what it was
yep yes yeah like that's huge
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right it was
like bob no he drake
trey doesn't have his name i was
thinking he was a slim
guy that just like not in that good
shape no you just said no yeah you know
like fight club guy with
giant action no old woman boobs he
doesn't have meatloaf titties but dre's
good he's good
that's correct you know what it is if
you've seen the
video that i put out the man boobs it's
that guy
okay all right so whatever you classify
him as all right
i don't want to sit here and talk about
those man's tits yeah
yes you do and keep eye contact stare me
and i'll stare at him but
uh i gotta go
oh oh uh uh oh but he so i did i was
doing that song
about man boobs and i had him come out
and dance behind me
and um and he was doing this to a guy in
the front row shaking his boobs
and the dude in the front row just
licked the guy's nipple and i was like
how was i going i was like here we go
it was bananas but we have a fun time on
my live show soon
that's awesome it's in tennessee where
can everybody see you at when you're
back home
oh uh on the road it um
i'm coming to oklahoma city to bricktown
um
in july there it is oh perfect
and then uh july 22nd 23rd 24th
bricktown
comedy club if you're in nashville i'm
there on the 25th doing one of those
kind of
weird variety shows and then west palm
beach
29th 30th and 31st
and then you guys can just go comedian
joshua.com for two dates there it is
got comedianjoshwolf.com dates on the
books damn
yeah how is it before you leave i like
being back on the road i love it man
yeah because when we talked to you last
it was not that way yeah i know i love
it
i i love it i really like being on stage
i really do like it's [ __ ] fun
and it's fun again you know i think
i think the break did me good good [ __ ]
yeah you're one of the comics that
the pandemic brought the best out of i
feel like yes with all the live [ __ ] and
the interaction is what
made me build up a huge fan base yeah
what made it cool
i tagged you on some tick tock [ __ ] i
don't use tick tock that much but some
comedy page posted a clip of yours oh
really
and it's got millions and millions and
millions of views on it
and i looked at it and i go oh josh let
me tag him
it's not gonna matter in the [ __ ] 300
000 comments and [ __ ]
and it's it's it's good it's just bread
and butter
and i just saw oh josh posted damn
he does millions of [ __ ] views on
this [ __ ] maybe he'll post another one
and get some more reviews for me
but they're enough for like i think
that's hard it's just a bunch of kids
dancing yeah
i gotta tell you something they've taken
more of my videos down they took that
man boobs video down i think a lot of
mine down too
because they called it an adult yours
was joint
yours is bullying my no oh is that what
it is yeah
it's considering you're talking about
anybody's body if you're like you're
here
but you can be 14 and yes
math on youtube yes yeah the guy that
smokes meth on youtube
and then we get in trouble that that was
bullying
that was bullying oh man no audience
[ __ ] i've been watching these war-torn
documentaries all week all this crazy
[ __ ] on
war-torn worst countries on earth babies
addicted to heroin and [ __ ] it's all on
there
yo we're leaving the podcast on that
note yeah oh my god
[Laughter]
i saw your finger i saw your head going
you're literally wrapping up those
[ __ ] babies are heroin
all right man thank you so much thank
you thank you uh josh wolfe it's
comedian joshwolf.com
comedian joshua.com and uh oh
hey one last thing i'm you know the high
life that i do
yes i'm moving it entirely
to patreon cool so like if anybody out
there is
so what where do we find it's
patreon.com
josh wolfe comedy patreon.com josh wolfe
comedy yeah
and uh because that show which weekly
yeah it's weekly it's ton of fun and we
it's a good time like we fun as [ __ ]
i've been on it twice twice or three
times
it's fun it's a good time man we do
silly [ __ ] but
um facebook is
is where it's it's just not not they're
not working with me
no [ __ ] no so it's time we it was time
to move it off there he's taking his
talents to patreon
exactly patreon yeah he'll be here
we'll link your [ __ ] yeah that would be
awesome i appreciate it guys and even if
you just want to check it out for a
month and see
if you're like this isn't for me
highlight is fun the highlights
the whole show in itself yeah yeah and
and we give fun weird [ __ ] away
yeah that the lid of the poster like oh
josh was coming it's very challenging
that's exactly why it's like oh it's
perfect josh is here
that's what would you do during my life
yeah yeah you've never given anything
away
we like to give [ __ ] away i but
sometimes i give things away that
that um just get left over from like
the shoots i was doing or and so
as a prop in one of my shows
we had a two-headed dildo but you
but my wife bought she was like i didn't
know which color you wanted so
and so there was one extra she went to
the store for you about it yeah
it sounded amazing so there was there
was one extra right
and um and you know
she was like we can just return it i'm
like they don't they don't take returns
on dildos
this one's ours you know what i'm saying
we have it yeah yeah
she was like they're not gonna take it
back i go no they're not taking the
[ __ ] dildo
i didn't i didn't touch it
yeah yeah i'm sorry you can't come in
it's okay uh
babies on heroin anyway double edges
give that away
on uh did you give that away or no the
dildo you gave away on your own oh so
on my last week's livestream i'm being
competent there's
there's another thing that i've been
trying to give away that nobody will
take
and it's a sequined it's a sequined
nic cage pillowcase and when you wipe it
his face goes away and you money wipe it
it comes back
nobody every time i put it up as a prize
somebody picks
the other thing so i was like [ __ ] this
week
i get the nic cage and i get the
two-headed dildo
[Laughter]
i hate you for the soundboard it's so
perfect it's coming in at the perfect
[ __ ] time
i saw his mouth open and it scared me at
first
it truly scared the [ __ ] out of me and
everyone driving just went
[Music]
you don't expect it if you don't expect
it it's scary it's super fun
it's funny just that's
the [ __ ] out of thomas last week yeah
the [ __ ] yeah that got me everybody gets
me every time
yo double ended dildo babies on heroin
title no we can't we can't
youtube will hate us and i'm going to
end it all right that's some of the
notes we went off on
i'm going to end it too thank you so
much for being here because you have a
show to do
you also have a texas hat on and that's
one thing i want to talk about you have
no time
you don't have a josh wolf head on we
have the joshua had over there
it's so different seeing you without a
different with a different head on yeah
it's so uh when you walk and go yeah
that's why you didn't recognize me no
i didn't recognize you you have a texas
hat on the guitar case
yeah yeah you scared the [ __ ] out of the
[ __ ] is this guy damn that's what we
started off and we end with it
that's what we're going to close with
comedianjoshwolf.com
come comedian joshua.com yeah
yeah well this set's going to go
terrible oh no you got it
you got it it's okay if you want awesome
you could just [ __ ] blame
one of your kids but i was you know my
kid well smoking the house up and got me
contact tonight we'll see if they're
still going on
i'd say we'll be all right thank you
guys so much for watching appreciate you
being here
you gotta go gotta go have a dope as day
thanks for watching guys
thanks everybody let's go later yes i
would call you uber right now
yeah yeah yeah uh this we can't be
eating raw it's too good
that's what she said
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]
perfect